like our friendly neighborhood
spider-man developer insomniac games has
rarely taken itself too seriously
it's protagonists range from talking
dragons to gun-toting lombaxes to punk
rock sanitation workers but also like
spider-man there is a wealth of ability
creativity and wisdom beneath that
playful veneer throughout the years
insomniac has bounced between 3d
platformers third-person action games
first-person shooters and open-world
playgrounds its portfolio is as colorful
as it is diverse yet in the grand scheme
of things the studio's expertise has
gone largely underappreciated insomniac
s-- 1998 breakout hits spyro sold almost
5 million copies the first retching
clank also sold well in 2002 breaking
3.5 million in sales and establishing a
new IP as the years rolled by however
the company's sales continually dropped
off now the games performed poorly by
any means but insomniac struggled to
regain the clout it had earned on the
ps1 the studio explored a darker tone
with 2006's resistance fall of man but
as was the case with ratchet the
franchise sold fewer copies with each
new release by the time insomniac
launched resistance 3 and it's decent
co-op shooter fuse we had already seen
ps3 standouts such as mgs for God of War
3 Gran Turismo 5 and the blockbuster
Uncharted Saga that's not to mention
third-party games such as call of duty
or grand theft auto
although insomniac played a crucial role
in the ps3s lifespan it's since taken a
historical backseat to the juggernauts
of its time
then came the newest console generation
and in 2014 the first insomniac title
made exclusively for a Microsoft
platform sunset overdrive is colorful
and abrasive it's on ashamed of its
goofy overtones it's also an insomniac
game in every sense with thrilling
platforming inventive weapons and a
refusal to take itself seriously it was
a critical darling and in my humble
opinion one of the best games on Xbox
one but this was a new IP early in a
console generation on a platform whose
sales had yet to gain momentum
despite sunset OverDrive's high purchase
rate for Xbox one owners it was no
commercial hit four years later it's
hailed as a
halt classic and in those intervening
four years insomniac games would double
down on its mantra of constant evolution
it experimented with VR creating a
competitive spell casting game a 3d
brawler and the fantastic horror title
edge of nowhere the studio also teamed
up with retailer Game Stop on song of
the deep a Metroidvania that doubled as
an outreach effort to gain stops
customers insomniac even branched into
cinema in 2016 it released the Ratchet
and Clank film to coincide with a
Ratchet and Clank remake on ps4 the
latter marked the company's first outing
on Sony's current console and a chance
to learn the ps4 s architecture for the
game it had planned next
throughout its history insomniac games
has been no stranger to success it's
been a staple of Sony's catalogues since
1998 it released one of the Xbox ones
most beloved titles to date its games
have frequently sold in the millions and
aside from several middling releases
found almost universal acclaim and
through it all the studio has managed to
remain independent but in a conversation
about respected triple-a developers
insomniac is often overshadowed by the
likes of Rockstar Naughty Dog Blizzard
Nintendo or say they project red
a few months ago insomniac CEO Ted Price
told the LA Times that the studio has
always seen themselves as somewhat of an
underdog and in a recent chat creative
director Brian in Tahar told me the same
thing so I guess it's fitting that
insomniac games is finally getting the
spotlight it deserves with one of pop
culture's most famous underdogs Peter
Parker the superhero toiling beneath a
mask for a city that often takes him for
granted a few years ago you might
remember the rumor circulating about the
next spider-man game according to the
supposed leak sucker punch the developer
behind the infamous series was working
on the marvel property at e3 2016
however insomniac announced that it was
behind the wheel the story that followed
was one of mythical proportions Marvel
in need of a talented triple-a studio
approached insomniac it gave the team
carte blanche to create a game based on
any Marvel superhero despite initial
resistance from insomniac executives who
were reluctant to work with an
established property the decision soon
became unanimous the team wanted to work
with spider-man
so with Sony's backing as the publisher
insomniac set to work bringing the
storied hero to life numerous companies
had attempted to do so and throughout
the course of the young medium only a
few had succeeded if you're watching
this then you now know insomniac was
more than ready for the challenge it
released a game that by most accounts
shouldn't exist it's thrilling polished
and has an attention to detail that
holds up to the most scrutiny of
Internet fans it surpassed two decades
worth of spider-man games and it did so
with the constant trust of one of the
most lucrative entertainment properties
today in the aforementioned conversation
in
also told me that he's not just proud of
leading development on a great
spider-man game or even a great Marvel
game more than anything he's proud of
creating a fantastic insomniac game you
can see that DNA in every aspect of
Spidey's world the movement and
traversal harken back to sunset
overdrive the gadgets and scientific
minigames pay homage to Ratchet and
Clank the weapon wheel might remind you
of resistance and the overall color
palette while obviously inspired by
spider-man's usual appearance also calls
to mind the art direction of insomniacs
whole portfolio the same qualities that
define insomniac for so long are finally
being touted on the main stage so to
speak and it's encouraging to see the
studio get the respect it has long
deserved insomniacs goals go even higher
than that however according to in Sahara
and Sami AK wanted this rendition of
Spider Man to be the Iron Man of Marvel
video games we you know some funny thing
that like Marvel and I talked a lot
about is this is the Iron Man this is
the one that's gonna start it off yeah
this is the one that's gonna like the
2008 film starring Robert Downey jr.
into heart hopes spider-man on ps4 would
force people to take future Marvel games
seriously by all accounts it seems
insomniac succeeded spider-man ps4 is
the fastest selling spider-man game ever
it is the best-selling Marvel branded
game of all time and as of this morning
it is the fastest selling first-party
playstation title it's raised
expectations for future Marvel titles
and once again cements insomniac as an
elite triple-a developer between its new
friendship with Marvel its ongoing
success with Sony and a massive
blockbuster hit under its belt I'm
willing to bet that insomniacs days as
the underdog are long gone
[Music]